TRAVEL ISSUES, WAS AN
UNDERSECRETARY OF HEALTH DURING
THAT SAME PERIOD.
HE SAYS HE DOES NOT RECALL BEING
NOTIFIED OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WERE REPORTED TODAY.
FROM CALIFORNIA NOW, A RED-HOT
ISSUE WENT TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL
THIS AFTERNOON.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SUING THAT
STATE OVER ITS REFUSAL TO
COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL LAW OVER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
AND IT'S GETTING NASTY IN THE
GOLDEN STATE.
CORRESPONDENT CLAUDIA COWAN HAS
THAT STORY TONIGHT IN
SACRAMENTO.
>> HOW DARE YOU NEEDLESSLY
ENDANGER THE LIVES OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO PROMOTE
A RADICAL OPEN BORDERS AGENDA?
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS THREW DOWN THE GAUNTLET
IN CALIFORNIA, BLASTING STATE
POLITICIANS FOR THEIR SANCTUARY
POLICIES, AND ACCUSING THEM OF
DELIBERATELY OBSTRUCTING FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW BY PROTECTING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY APPEARS
TO ME IS USING EVERY POWER IT
HAS COME UP IT DOESN'T HAVE, TO
FRUSTRATE FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOWED HIS
SUPPORT WHILE SPEAKING TO THE
LATINO COALITION EARLIER TODAY.
>> IT'S DESTROYING PEOPLE'S
LIVES, SO MANY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO STOP AT THE.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING THREE
CALIFORNIA STATE LAWS ENACTED
WITHIN THE PAST YEAR.
ONE PROHIBITS LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM ASKING PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND FROM
PARTICIPATING IN FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT RAIDS.
ANOTHER GIVES A STATE OFFICIAL'S
POWER OVER DHS DETENTION
FACILITIES, AND THE THIRD OFFERS
PROTECTION AGAINST WORKPLACE
RAIDS.
THIS LAWSUIT MARKS AN ESCALATION
IN THE ONGOING FEUD BETWEEN THET
IN THE ONGOING FEUD BETWEEN THEE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
IMMIGRATION ADVOCATES.
HUNDREDS OF WHOM SHOWED UP TO
PROTEST, CHANTING "SHUT IT DOWN"
AND BROCK TO BLOCKING THE STREET
AROUND THE HOTEL.
CALIFORNIA'S DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL ANGRILY
CONDEMNED THE DOJ LAWSUIT AS A
POLITICAL STUNT, CONTENDING
MAYOR STATES SANCTUARY POLICIES
ARE ON SOLID LEGAL GROUND.
>> THIS IS COMPLETELY
UNPRECEDENTED FOR THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO COME OUT HERE AND ENGAGE IN A
POLITICAL STUNT, MAKE WILD
ACCUSATIONS, MANY OF WHICH ARE
BASED ON OUTRIGHT LIES.
>> THE LAWSUIT CHALLENGES SOME
OF OUR STATE LAWS, WHICH ARE
AGAIN, FULLY CONSTITUTIONAL.
>> IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH FOX NEWS' SHANNON BREAM,
SESSIONS VOWED TO KEEP FIGHTING.
>> SOMEBODY NEEDS TO STAND UP
AND SAY NO, YOU'VE GONE TOO FAR,
YOU CANNOT DO THIS, THIS IS NOT
REASONABLE, IT'S RADICAL REALLY.
>> AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
REPORTEDLY NOW LOOKING AT OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE SANCTUARY
POLICIES THEY COULD FACE LEGAL
ACTION NEXT.
MEANWHILE, AND CALIFORNIA, BOTH
SIDES ARE GEARING UP FOR A LONG
LEGAL FIGHT, NO MATTER WHAT THE
DISTRICT JUDGE DECIDES.
THE LOSER WILL APPEAL IN THIS